hi my name is philip and welcome to
let's talk religion
on this channel we talk about
religion and we do so from an academic
and scholarly perspective i have a
master's degree in
comparative religion also known as
religious studies and i try to bring
that expertise and experience when i do
these videos on this channel you will
find introductory videos about various
religious traditions
including the great
world religions but also smaller
traditions you also find deep dives into
obscure philosophers or theologies from
different religious traditions as well
as more documentary style videos where
we
explore and talk to religious
practitioners from different religions
as well there's no doubt that religion
is a massively important factor in the
world today both in terms of politics
but just society at large and yet the
religious literacy of many people is
very lacking when we have discussions on
this topic we often end up talking
across each other and never actually
meeting in a proper discussion because
there's a lack of understanding a lack
of education on these topics and that is
why it is so important that we increase
the religious literacy in the world that
we educate ourselves more about
religions how they work about other
people's religions in order that we can
meet and discuss and thus be able to
understand each other better and through
that hopefully we can achieve a world
with more understanding and tolerance
and that is what we try to do here at
let's talk religion we tackle various
topics of religion from a academic and
scholarly perspective based on
scientific research done by scholars and
thus try to present these topics from a
position that is as neutral and
objective as possible to provide you
with information that is trustworthy and
useful but also hopefully interesting
and engaging so again welcome to this
channel and i hope to see you in the
comments thank you
[Music]
foreign